Oh a foo is when we learn to do poi type
movements with the arms and this is
great for developing a lot of control of
the body and as we progress will
eventually start learning to do those
movies with poi will add poi to the poi
Fuu so we'll often be doing what we call
Peruvian arms which at first will be
just with the arms as we develop good
posture good technique with the body
good alignments with the body good lines
with the body and then we'll add POI so
we're gonna learn the beginning of plate
Trivium arms you can take one hand take
your right hand let's face this way
together and you're gonna hold it in
front of you like it's a mirror and
you're looking at yourself and you know
take a moment appreciate yourself thank
you for being me then you're going to
relax at your arm open and the hand goes
to the back your head goes right past
your ear then you just reach up and let
it drop down the side right on the side
it swoops past your legs and comes back
to your nose so it goes right past your
ear reach and swoop past your ear
reach and past the ear and you want to
develop again it's muscle memory if you
don't practice it you'll very easily
switch to doing all kinds of funny
things right at the moment you're
thinking about something else so in the
beginning you want to really think knows
past the ear and open nose past the ear
and open and you really want full
movement so you don't just cut from here
to your nose let it really swoop in a
nice circle past your legs to nose and
really it reaches up like this a bell up
here big circle past the legs and swoops
around swoop and around and swoop and
around and swoop in the rat I mirror you
it's like this see what I mean it
doesn't cut up the front it swoops past
the leg if I do that it's already going
this way past my nose if I go like this
it's going this way past my nose
so it swoops past the nose and opens sue
passed the notes and open some passing
notes and open right now it's four cans
left hand pass the ear and open swoop so
you can think you're listening to a
seashell then you're listening to the
ocean in the seashell open past the nose
listen and open past the nose listen
openly and with practice this gets
really relaxed and you want to think
about your good posture so you think
about whether you've got this nice tall
spine yeah whether your chest is open
because employee people if they're
thinking too much they often start
thinking doing this and you really want
to develop some habits of where you're
standing tall looks nicer and it's much
better for your body so ultimately this
will relax and it starts being this nice
circular movement and it's a really good
way to open up and lubricate your
shoulders that's a warm-up so with
practice you can go the right as it
comes down you go left right left right
left right left
it's okay if that isn't smooth this week
sometimes I'll say you need things to be
smooth to progress other times I'll say
don't worry just play with it a bit it's
okay if it's awkward so it's okay if
this is a bit awkward right left we can
also do the the reverse of this which is
where you take your right hand you're
gonna raise it up and it gets to the top
it relaxes to the back of the head it
goes past the ear past the nose and
drops past the legs now this is where
the posture is important because if
you're selecting at all it's gonna your
arms gonna go like this you're gonna go
boom if you stand tall with the heart
open breathe in the hand will naturally
come to the back of the head and then
used to relax it was past the ear past
the nose and drops back the head ear
nose we back the head ear nose and you
want to make sure let it be a full
movement don't cut to here
don't get halfway and cut to the back of
the head let it make a big circle and
come to the back of the head and do a
nice big swoop swish and a big swoop
swish the left hand big swoop swish and
big swoop see if you stand tall bill
comes to back your head around drop up
to the back of the head around drop up
back head make circles past the ear past
the ear then the nose and then drop past
the back the head your nose yeah close
we're gonna build on this each week
we're gonna take our time with this so
all you really need this week is each
hand in each direction and what I really
want you to focus on is the body good
posture heart open shoulders very gently
rolled back very gently until you can
stay relaxed and the arms can gently go
through these motions and we're going to
slowly build it will be adding poi all
kinds of fun stuff will come out of this
so yeah enjoy